should I just walk in or should I do the
whole like stopping every like five
seconds
so right now my boyfriend is in the
other room and he thinks that we're here
just to talk about our dream wedding but
surprise him and put on a wedding dress
I hope he has a really good reaction
because it's something that I've been
waiting for like 12 years you know when
you see those videos it's like oh if I'm
walking down the aisle and my boyfriend
doesn't like Cryer how that reaction I'm
gonna go pack him up again
Tim and I think about getting married
all the time she may not know this but I
think about it more than she does simply
because she is so deserving I am 30 she
is 29 so we see ourselves having kids in
the next maybe two and a half years
three years my thing of a dream wedding
is just simply inviting all our friends
all my family I want there to be a
routine that being a couple of friends
you know family practice out on the
dance floor and we do a special dance
form that's the only thing that I want I
would like to get married in a place
that resembles of a barn or a farm not
extremely fancy but it's you really well
decorated okay I think this is the one I
hope it fits I know when they go back
and forth and travel dresses like I feel
sometimes I actually feel nice you just
have to stop eating for like a good four
days just to fit into it dress like this
for what I'm good I'm just so scared
because like I've never been in a
wedding dress before we've been to so
many weddings and stuff like that and
so raise me watching the other woman
like getting married and having the
white dress on it was really random and
probably very weird of me but it brought
my grandma's pearls cuz I figured if I'm
tryna wearing dress for the first time
my zone with the accessories I plan
actually what makes me attracted to Cali
is besides her looks which is not the
most important thing is her character
her laughter is very contagious
she is very understanding extremely
intelligent she's a great whole person
she is marked as I said and knows how to
dance very well and I'm blessed to be
what should be her partner what I love
about Tim is that Tim is the complete
opposite of me knowing myself in the
past I have known to be very very
complacent just satisfied with who I was
and what I was doing in life and I
wanted to go I want to swim with the
strange thing about Tim is that she
swims against the stream you know she
was - she wants to dream a little she
wants to go out we live when it comes to
when it comes to language because you
can always talk to people based on
what's going on I don't know genuinely
I'm nervous
did you expect this no did you maybe
since we're here I was wondering if you
wanted to just get married today I told
them that you know you were waiting for
12 years I've been nervous all day long
because I really didn't know what to
expect
are you sure good we came this one might
as well you know it's been 12 years are
you guys ready I'm ready
dearly beloved and honoured guests
that's the three of you behind the
cameras they were asking me about what
would be my outfit like for the wedding
day and I was saying that would be
something classic but it's still a
stylish that would be wearing suspenders
please announce you man what you may
kiss the bride and I read to
when I first seen her I was like oh she
looks so beautiful is she gonna sit down
next to me yeah I think we're gonna
stand up and then I seen Steven after
and I was like wait oh that's what kind
of part of the glass the reaction that I
thought I was gonna get from him was
what's going on like I'm not ready
because I don't have the the real things
yeah I'm not looking right like I
couldn't have asked for a better
reaction I mean I didn't think that you
would cry honestly he's not really
easily to cry this is the person that I
really feel intrigued about attracted to
in love with and yeah my sweaty girl
right here I feel liberated like a big
weight has been lifted off my shoulders
because it's been a long time coming
even if it was a prank I still feel the
love and I still feel like it was you
know you know I really appreciate her
pranking a hell out of me we've heard on
my side doesn't matter fears can't come
we're gonna go through anything he's
just the sweetest person I've ever met
so bring in the priest
[Music]